hollywood should not have people
audition for one line it's [ __ ]
ludicrous it's shitty it's a waste of
time people are battling three hours of
traffic to drive down a [ __ ] santa
monica and go up to the 19th floor and
just say what the [ __ ] she's saying hire
someone off a picture furthermore do
commercials [ __ ] just hire someone
off of the off of the picture dude it's
so [ __ ] annoying and it's okay and
it's a power move and they're doing it
because they're the big [ __ ]
and you will drive there of course
you're not going to band together and
not go because you got to [ __ ] eat
and you want to become that actress or
actor but
acting at a certain level is hard it's
hard to book a role and it's hard to
play like brian cranston in breaking bad
that role is [ __ ] a difficult role to
play but for the most part and i mean 99
percent of stuff
it's [ __ ] easy
as [ __ ]
stop acting like it's hard you aren't a
brain surgeon you're
only saying
easy [ __ ] dude that's
it
that's it it's so simple it's so simple
unless you're doing king speech
or some [ __ ] like that and really
selling it or you're doing the [ __ ]
fighter like christian bale and you're
losing a bunch of weight and you're
acting all [ __ ] strung out it's easy
as [ __ ] dude don't give me [ __ ] like
captain america playing captain america
is easy it's easy bro long days
bro be a [ __ ] tannin bomb be a
bricklayer
now that's good
chris isn't upset at all about how no no
i love it it's just annoying no it's not
hollywood it's the actors dude
you're not yelling at us
yeah you dude yeah did you not get that
you're upset about no it's not about
that you can't even act like you believe
in god like the rest of us yeah
i'll do it right now ready do it
dude unreal they did an x-ray of him bro
it was just a dog getting hit by a van
dude there's nothing in him no i will
answer this it's so easy it's so easy to
act well yes absolutely
look yeah i i completely disagree i
think that there are things that are
like whatever but i think
some of the things have to do with like
the person's charisma the person's like
a lot of things
are funny but that's not actually
not really yes it is
if you're playing yourself it has to be
pretty [ __ ] easy you play yourself a
lot you play yourself a lot that's not
true if you're daniel day lewis no i do
crazy [ __ ] like that no you never see me
walk around in my house i could kill it
dude if i
if i if they put me playing somebody
with like they never would but like and
i'm just not even trying to push the
limits but if i wanted if they wanted me
to play somebody with down syndrome
do i get nominated they're not do it
they're not going to do that do peanut
butter number two get do it
okay let's go look guys
he's going to hell we know he's going to
hell what are you saying thunderbird
what is going on thunder you can't you
can't go full [ __ ] i know i'm not i'm
not i'm not
[Laughter]
sean penn played that [ __ ] role and
he killed it he played a guy with down
syndrome and i'm just saying with me if
i were to do it where's all that chicken
i had
with all that chicken i had what did all
that chicken i had mom no that's your
friend mark
it sounds like marquez that's some guy
that works at a pop-up
that's all
he doesn't he doesn't
[Laughter]
[Music]
legendary trio brenden chris and theo
what you mean you know it's the king and
the sting and the wing
[Music]